hey this is presh talwalker consider the
graph of the ellipse x squared over 9
plus y squared is equal to 1 in the
first quadrant
graph the line Y is equal to X over 2
and consider the region bounded by this
line the ellipse and the x-axis
now consider the same ellipse in the
first quadrant and consider the line Y
is equal to MX
now consider the region bounded by this
line the ellipse and the y-axis
the question is to solve for the value
of M so the green and blue areas are
equal
a version of this problem appeared on
the 1994 Putnam exam and I think nierman
for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
there's an incredible trick to solve
this problem
we will do a change of coordinates with
a linear transformation let X1 be equal
to X over 3 and let y1 be equal to Y so
in the X Y plane we have the graph of an
ellipse
what will happen after this linear
transformation the ellipses will turn
into circles and the regions will turn
into circular sectors
now the original green and blue areas
will be equal if and only if the
transformed green and blue areas are
equal because we've done a linear
transformation that stretches both areas
by the same factor
so now let's see where the lines go the
line Y is equal to X over 2 will become
the line y1 is equal to 3 x 1 over 2.
now this green area will be equal to the
blue area if and only if they are
reflections of each other about the line
y1 is equal to X1
so let's take this line y1 is equal to
3x1 divided by two
and let's reflect it about the line y1
is equal to X1 to do that we change the
y1 and X1 coordinates and then we can
solve for y to get y1 is equal to 2x1
divided by 3.
so we've solved for this line in the
green region now all we have to do is
transform it back into our original
coordinates
so we will do a change of coordinates
back we will now do the reverse
transformation that X is equal to 3x1
and Y is equal to y1 upon this
transformation we get the line Y is
equal to 2x divided by 9. therefore m is
equal to 2 over 9 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign